social media helped uncover the final
steps of a Connecticut man who was
murdered in New York City Joey come on
ollie been a vanished after a night of
clubbing he attended an after-party in
the upscale home of James rack over the
son of a jeweler to the Stars the common
alley didn't leave the apartment alive
he died of multiple stab wounds for
tomorrow's 48 hours Erin Moriarty spoke
to his family and friends about the
disappearance
Joey's missing he's somewhere it's gotta
be somewhere
hey where's Joey have you heard from
Joey Joey common Ali's father Pat knew
his 26 year old son well and at first he
wasn't worried when he couldn't reach
him on Sunday morning November 13 2016
Joey had gone clubbing with friends the
night before a bunch of people were
going out to New York City that night we
went to the gilded Lily the gilded lily
is in the Meatpacking District
it's a lounge he has club type music
every 30 or so than I was on doing so
everyone exits
I remember Joey on my left and these
girls were looking at him a certain way
and he was looking back at me and just
smiling like you know that he was
interested even naso says he drove his
girlfriend back home to Stamford
Connecticut while Joey went off with
those women and some guys he had just
met to a small party in the exclusive
Manhattan neighborhood known as Sutton
Place you're not expecting an issue in
some place Sutton Place is a beautiful
place to live the party was an apartment
4c at the Grand Sutton it was the home
of 25-year old James rackover the son of
jeffrey rackover the so called jeweler
to the stars his clients included Oprah
Winfrey JLo even President Trump and his
wife Melania what could go wrong on the
Upper East Side but by the next
afternoon no one could find Joey not his
father not his friends that's when
everyone jumped on social media I went
on Facebook I went on Instagram
did you ever tried to track down or
retrace somebody steps before using
social media no you're in a panic and
you're trying to find your your friend
[Applause]
Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday it
Joey's father Pat headed to the grand
Sutton with detectives from the NYPD and
spotted on surveillance video his son
walking into the building I said to
myself I don't think he walked out of
the building alive when investigators
zeroed in on the party host James Rock /
they discovered a man with secrets and a
dark past
James rackover wasn't really James
rackover was it no what do you think
happened in apartment 4c Erin Moriarty
is with us now Erin so explain the word
about how social media helped them this
made a huge difference if if they hadn't
started this investigation another 24
hours we'd be saying whatever happened
to Joey common le his friends as soon as
they realized he was missing within
hours
one thing they went on was Instagram
their locator function and there are
pictures other people posted and they
found one of the women who had been at
the party with Joey through her they got
a name and a telephone number
I never realized any of this they put it
in Google they got his Facebook page so
within hours the police had the name of
one of the suspects I learned so much
doing this but what was so unusual about
this case is we never worried about
young men like that yeah this guy Joey
common Ally was an athlete he was savvy
he was smart he thought he was going to
a home of a but you know I love Eric to
a fortunate you think you've bonded with
some people that you met overnight I got
my heart broke for the common Ally
family because he was a good kid from
the state of Connecticut and just met up
with the wrong people was a
heartbreaking story and truly a victim
yes he was
Thank You Erin and you can watch Erin's
full report what happened in apartment
4c that's tomorrow night and it is part
of a 48 hours double feature that begins
at 9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS